والله أبو يوسف واحد مثل هالرجال،
لا أقل ولا أكثر
فيه ناس سبقونا بالطيب،
وفيه ناس سبقونا بالكرم،
وفيه ناس سبقونا بالمعرفة،
عِرف الدلال
أنا إلى الآن مبتدئ، مبتدئ بالحياة
معرفتي بالحياة ولا 1% صراحةً
أول حمسة قهوة لي
كنت في أول متوسط أو ثاني متوسط
كنت حاط الحماسة على النار،
وباليد الثانية يد المحماسة
فلمّا خلصت
يد المحماسة نزلتها على الأرض
ما انتبهت صراحةً إلا بشيء ضربني على رأسي
من شدته ما أدري أيش اللي جاني
طلع أبوي
قال ولدي عيب تنزل المحماسة بالأرض
ولما جيت بطبخ القهوة قال أبوي:
توضأ
استغربت أنا، قلت:
أبوي ما رح أصلّي
قال: توضّ!،
قمت وتوضّيت
أعرف إذا قال الكلمة مرة ومرتين،
الثالثة لا يقولها
لا يقول الثالثة
رحت وتوضّيت
لمّا جيت أجلس وأبدأ أطبخ القهوة،
قال: شوف يا ولدي
القهوة نفّس
إذا فكرك أو نفّسك مو حلو، لا تطبخ القهوة
وداعتك لا تصلح القهوة إلا وأنت متوضئ
فمن ذاك اليوم إلى اليوم،
ما أصلح القهوة إلا وأنا متوضئ
العام الماضي كنت هناك، والسنة هذه صرت هنا
ثامر: وأعجبك هذا المكان؟
إيه والله حلو وقريب،
وسهل للقادمين من الشارع
ثامر: مين اللي عنده بيت شعر هناك؟
هذا من قريب نازل، ما أدري مين هو
أطلع له إذا شب النار في الخيمة،
وأتقهوى عنده وأعزمه على العشاء
أقول له عندي عشاء الليلة في خيمتي،
تفضّل حياك الله
أو هو يجي يتقهوى عندي ويقول العشاء عندي
كانوا الأولين، بمجرد ما يسمعون دقّ النجر
فلان هذا دقّ نجره، يلا نروح نتقهوى عنده
إذا وصلوا كبار السن المجلس وجلسوا،
طول الله عمرك
لو ما هم منتبهين للمضيف، تلقاهم يسولفون
مجرد أنه يدقّ الهيل،ودنّ النجر
وكأنه يقول للضيوف كلوا من التمر
هو جهّز القهوة خلاص
وهذا اللي ماشيين عليه عندنا هنا
مجرد ما أدنّ النجر، فيعني أني بهّرت القهوة
فكُل من التمر قبل القهوة، ما عندك مشكلة
هذه عادات وماشين عليها
بالنسبة للمصنع، تأسّس عام 1403 هـ
لكن فكرة الوالد كانت موجودة من قبل،
ممكن من عام 1398هـ أو 1397 هـ
هذا كلام الوالد لي
ثلاث سنين إلى أن أنتج دلة قهوة صحيحة 100%
ويعني شافها دلة صحيحة،
مسك الدلة ودقّق النظر لها
وقال:
فعلًا هذه دلّة!
هذه من ابداعاتي، طال عمرك
سميناها «دلة أبو يوسف»
بالنسبة للدلة هذه
دخّلت عليها يمكن
أربعة تصاميم لدلال مختلفة
عندك المشرب طولته،
الغطاء خليته مسطح على النمط البغدادي،
الدلة على تصميم دلة هادي صالح
مقبض الدلة رفعته شوي، من هنا
بالعادة يجي نازل، لا هذا شوي رفعته
هذا الغطاء على نمط الدلة الحساوية، فتحته
نمط الدلة البغدادية يكون دائمًا قصير
فخلّيته على النمط الحساوي، ويكون بعيد شوي
في الوقت هذا
اللي يجيك، يجيك متفضّل
يعني هو فاتح بابه، وبيّض الله وجهه
لكن يوم يجيك، يجيك متفضّل
لأن كل واحد عنده قهوة، وكل واحد عنده تعليلة
الحين أيش بهار القهوة؟
الهيل
أيش بهار البيت؟
الرجال
اذا جوا الرجال البيت ودخلوه
يتبارك البيت سبحان الله،
ويصير له قيمة ويصير له طعم
ثامر: أيش ينبت في الأرض هذه؟
هذا «العاذر» و«الأرطى»
«الأرطى» هذا الكبير،
والباقي أكثره «العاذر»
هذا البيت الحين
أصب للأطفال الماء على التراب،
فيلعبون فيه ويسوّون شكل الكيك
مثلنا زمان كنّا نسمّيه الكيك
يعملون كيكة ويرسمون عليها
هذا شيء تستانس فيه
يوم تعمل لأطفالك مجسمات من التراب،
ويرسمون عليها
اترك الطفل يلعب بالتراب، اتركه يحوس ويدوس
مصيره يروح ويتروش
نظرة الإنسان للشجر،
ونظرته للحياة وطبيعة الأرض
ما راح يتصورها،
لو يجلس بالبيت طول حياته، ما راح يتصوره
الأولين إذا انصب لهم فنجال،
قبل لا يشرب الفنجال تلقاه ينظر له
هذه أول شيء
نظرته للفنجال عشان لون القهوة
هل فيه بقايا القهوة، أو ما فيه بقايا؟
اللي هو الحثل
وقبل لا يشرب،
تلقاه يأخذ نفس ويشم رائحة القهوة
فيشرب الفنجال الأول ليتذوّقه
السلام عليكم!
يا هلا.. يا هلا بالشيخ علوش
هلا بك يا شيخ مزيد
يا هلا بابن ظويهر
هلا بك
في قصر برزان هذاك الوقت
عاد على وقت الإمام محمد المهاد
أو على وقت طلال
والله ما أدري أيّهم بالضبط
وقالوا على وقت محمد
يُقال يوم صبوا له الفنجال،
شرب من الفنجال
أحس إن القهوة فيها شيء
فكبّ الفنجال وما شربه، وشافه الأمام
قال: ليش يا علوش كبيت الفنجال؟
يُقال إنه جاوب: مو طيّبة أو زي كذا،
أو قال ما أشتهي
قال الإمام: ليش كبيت الفنجال؟
قال: القهوة مو طاهرة، أو أن بها شيء،
ومن هذا الكلام
قال علوش: يا أن السبب في الرجال اللي يصب القهوة
أو الدلال
فيُقال كبّوا الدلة ولقوا حبة شعير
أو يُقال لقوا بالقهوة نملة
أيش اللي خلاه يميّز هذا الطعم؟
في دلة بهذا الكبر
ومن نملة صغيرة أو حبة شعير؟
أيش اللي خلّاه يميز؟
قال الإمام:
اشهدوا علي يالربع
هو يقول، قال الإمام:
ترا حبّ القهوة وهيلها، ولوازمها كلها
ترا علي إلين تموت يا علوش بن ظويهر
يقول أبوي في هذاك الوقت
كنّا في دار بالحفير ذلك الوقت،
يقول:
ضمن الأحاديث اللي تحزّ في خاطري
يقول دقّ قهوته وبهّرها في دلّة صغيرة، نفس هذه
وحط البهار وسوّا القهوة طال عمرك
ومعه ثلاث فناجيل
بس؟
بس
يقول 14 رجال موجود في الغرفة
في دار طين، 14 رجال
وبهذه الثلاث فناجيل، يصب لكل واحد فنجال
ويرجع للأول ويأخذ الفنجال، بس فنجال واحد
يمشي إلى أن صبّ لكل واحد بهذه الثلاث فناجيل
خلصوا، فراح غسل الدلّة
وحط سكر وشاي، وسوّا فيها شاي
وضيّفهم
ما عندي مشكلة،
أتقهوى قهوة مختصة زي ما يقولون
أتقهوى ما عندي مشكلة
أمر لي مقهى إذا مشتهي في يوم
لكن أبقى على ما أنا عليه
ما أتصنّع!
عشان الشكل الجديد؟ ما أتصنّع
مهما ارتفعت أو نزلت، تبقى مثل ما أنت
مصيرك آخر شيء التراب
الملوك الحين... الملوك
مهما وصلوا من التطور،
ووصلوا أنهم يشربون قهوة مختصة
إلا انهم ما يقدمون بمجلس الضيافة،
إلا دلة قهوة!
دلة رسلان صحيح!
تلقى إذا وقف القهوجي يصبّ القهوة،
وقفته صحيحة وشامخة
عشان اللي قدامه ملك؟
ما أتوقع
عشان الحضور
هذا فخر السعودية
تبقى مثل ما أنت، على شماغك وعلى ثوبك
ليش إذا جاء يوم التأسيس،
رجعت على التراث ولبست تراثي؟
أيش السبب؟
ترجع على الأصل! ترجع على الأساس!
هذا هو اللي إحنا نريده،
ابقَ على ما أنت عليه،
تطور وامش مع الناس،
ما عندك مشكلة،
اشتر جوال والبس ساعة،
البس اللي أنت تلبس
لكن ابقَ على ما أنت عليه، لا تتصنع!
فتنكسر بعدين!